サップバパスアカラナン クサラッソ ウパ サンパンダ サチッタ パリオ タプナング エタム ブッダンサーサナナム
ではあの五戒文のナモタッサ
ナモー トassa バガワトー アラハトー スマー サームブッドサス ナモー トassa バガワトー アラハトー サムー サーブットサス
ブッ당 シャレナン ガッチャーミ
ブッダンシャランアンガジャミー
ダンマーン シャレナン カチャーーミー
ダンマンシャラン アンガチャーミー
サンガン シャラナン ガッジャーミー
シャンハン シャラナム ガッチャミー
デュティアピ ブッダん シャラナン がっちゃーみぃー
ビィ ダンダン サラナン ガッチャン
ドゥディアンジ ピ ダンマン シャラナン ガッチャ ミー
ダンマン サラナンガチャミー
ドゥッテー ヤンピー サンガン シャラナン ガッチャ ミー
ピー サンガン サラナン ガッシャーミー
サティー ang ピー ブッダん シャラナン ガッチャ ハーミー
タン サナンガ チャールディ
サティヤンピー ダンマ ラン サラナン ガッチャハーミー
ピー ダン マンス ラナンガ ジャム
サティ ヤンピー サンガン シュラン サラナン ガッチャー メェ
ピー サンガン サラナン ガッチャミー
パーナーティ パーター ヴェーラマニー シックファー padang サマーディーアーミー
ラーティーパーウェーラマネー シカーパラウン サマジアミー
アディング アーダーナー ウェーラマニー シッカー Padang サマーディーアーミー
アミンナーデーラ マニーシーカーファランドン సమాジアミー
カーメースミッチャチャーラー ウェーラマニー シッカーPadang サマーディア ミー
スー ニッチャーチャー的味道 マニー シッパー ファラム サマディア
ムサーワーザー ウェーラマニー シッカーpadang サマダイヤ ミー
サーバーだぁ でらまに しっかあ padang サマジヤ
す拉めーら まっじょぱまぁ だったなぁ
웨ーラマニー シッカー pads サマーディア ミー
しゃばまたったなウェーラマニー シッカーパダン サマイアミー
懺悔致します 無明の中に覆われて身口意の三業によって犯してしまった過ちがあります
父母僧に対する過ち 法師に対する過ち
生きとし生けるものに対する過ち
これは一切の過ちを懺悔いたします
また 自分が受けた他の一人一人の過ちも許します
このように雑事を離れ
一人静かに自己の心身を得を持って見つめる時
瞬間瞬間変化消滅している現象をヴィパッサナーによって考察し
真の幸福を得て解脱の道へ導かれますようにとここに請願をいたします
ナモー
タッサ ヴァデヴァトー アレハトー サッマー サンブッダッサーナモー タッサ ヴァデヴァトー ア
レハトー サッマー サンブッダッサーナモー タッサ ヴァデヴァトー アレハトー サッマー サンブッダッサー
イティピ
ソー ヴァデヴァー アラン サッマー サンブッドー ヴィッジャーチャラーナ サンパンノー スガトー ローカ ヴィドゥー
アヌッタロー プーリセ ダンマサーラティー サッターデーヴァ マヌッサーナン ブッドー ヴァデヴァーティー サンジーヴィタ
パリアンタン サラナン ガッチャーミー
サーカート
ー ヴァデヴァター ダンモー サンディッティコー エーイ パッスィコー オパナイコー パッチャッタン ヴェーディタム ボー ヴィッニュー イーティ
ダンマン ジーヴィタ パリアンタン サラナン ガッチャーミー
スーパティパンモー ヴァデヴァトー さーヴァカ サンゴー ウジューパティパンモー ヴァデヴァトー さーヴ
ァカ サンゴー ニャーヤパティパンモー ヴァデヴァトー さーヴァカ サンゴー サミーチパティパンモー ヴァデヴァトー さーヴァカ サンゴー
ヤディダン チャッターリ プーリセ ヨガーニ アッタ プーリセ プンガラー エーサ ヴァデヴァトー さーヴァカ サンゴー
アウネイヨ パウネイヨ ダッキーネイヨ アンジェリカーラネイヨ
アヌッタラン プンニャッケットン ローカッサティー サンガン ジーヴィタ パリアン...ブッダング
サリナング ガッチャミー
サーリプッタ サーリプッタ
カーエナ ワーチャ チッテーナ
パマーデーナ マヤーカタン
アッチャヤンカムメ バンテー
ブーリパンニャー タターガタ
カーエナ ワーチャ チッテーナ
パマーデーナ マヤーカタン
アッチャヤンカムメ ダンマ
サンディッティカ アカーリカ
カーエナ ワーチャ チッテーナ
パマーデーナ マヤーカタン
アッチャヤンカムメ サンガ
スーパティパンナ アヌッタラ
サード サード  慈悲の瞑想いたします
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み 苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願い事が叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように
私は幸せでありますようにと念じます
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
私の親しい生命の悩み
苦しみがなくなりますように
私の親しい生命の願い事が叶えられますように
私の親しい生命にも悟りの光が現れますように
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
親しい生命が幸せでありますようにと念じます
[silence]生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと念じます
私の嫌いな生命が幸せでありますように
私の嫌いな生命の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の嫌いな生命の願いごとが叶えられますように
私の嫌いな生命にも悟りの光が...
が現れますように 私を嫌っている生命が幸せでありますように
私を嫌っている生命の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私を嫌っている生命の願い事が叶えられますように
私を嫌っている生命にも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
はい ありがとうございます
皆様方はお釈迦様の誕生日浄土初涅槃をお祝いするための法要を今行っております
で 前半は今日で 後半は明日で行います
で 生きることっていうのは大変苦しいことで
我々はやっと苦労して命をつないでいるだけなんです
生きるためには この世界からいろんなものを奪わなくちゃいけなくなっているんです
だから 一人の人間が長生きしたとは
自然界に 他の生命に多大な迷惑をかけて生きたことになります
生きること自体は そんなに美しくて清らかで素晴らしいことではありません
私たちは一日でどれぐらい生命の体を食べているのかと考えると
その我々はいろいろご飯を食べると
誰かの生命が死ななくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
で それから地球の力も借りて
まあ生きてますけど これは地球の破壊にもなるし
他の生命の迷惑にもなるし
人間が地球の酸素はものすごい大量に無駄に使っているんですね
自分に与えられた分だけではないんですね
で 呼吸する分だけの酸素は自分に与えられたもので
しかし 最低料理する時でも我々は酸素を燃やしているんだからね
他の生命は料理しません
ですから 我々は余分に地球の財産を奪っているんですね
その上 飛行機に乗ったり
車を運転したりするんだから
どれほど自然界のね 酸素がまあ強引に使っているのかと
そういうことで 生きることっていうのは
奪って奪って奪ってやることになります
だから ものを奪うことは
与えられてないものを取ることで
仏教的には罪になりますね
です とは言っても 我々は生きていて何をやっているのかというと
結局は誰だってやっていることで
勉強するは 仕事をするは
結婚をするは 子育てをするは
それから年を取るは死ぬは
それだけなんですね それもまあ世界が言っていることを馬鹿みたくやっているだけで
そこでお釈迦様がこの悪循環から脱出してくださいと
奪うことの代わりに与えることをしなさいと
生命を無差別に生命に邪魔をするんじゃなくて
苦しんでいる生命を慈しんでくださいと
我々には清らかな世界を案内したんですね
だから今からお釈迦様の世界に入って
お釈迦様の心の波長の中に入って
皆様方はすべての生命が幸福でありますように
すべての生命に涅槃安らぎがに達することができますように
すべての生命に輪廻転生することから脱出できますように
というブッダと同じ祈願で誓願で次のこの法要を行ってください
どうもありがとうございます
で では はい それでですね
あまりしゃべる必要はないね
一番ありがたいことに
この 我々を生かしている
生かされているエネルギーには業というんですね
何かあるエネルギーが働いてますよ
このエネルギーで呼吸することすら
だって筋肉仕事しなくちゃあかんでしょうに
こんな仕事仕事やるところで疲れて死んじゃいますよ
しかし 呼吸することであっても
この業が電池で働いているんです
だからすべて呼吸だけじゃない
脳みそであろうか 他の体の臓器であろうか
電池は業なんです で 新しい IPHONE と同じく
何回充電できると回数決まってあって
あまりにも IPHONE 使いすぎちゃって
1 日 2 3回充電しちゃうと
これは半年で処分する羽目になっちゃうんです
なぜならば 新しい電池入れ替えるよりは新しい携帯買った方が安いんです
だからこの まあそれは例え話でね
我々は生まれると電池ついて生まれるんです
この電池はものじゃないんだから
赤ちゃんにはまあ大丈夫です
しっかり死ぬまで生きるための電池がついているので
この電池が業というんです
それだったらどうなるのか
例えばね 携帯を持ってる場合は
携帯の能力はすべて揃っているでしょ
しかし どのように使うかというのは
その人の勝手なんですね
だから何も操作できない私の場合は
ただの宝の持ち腐れで持っているだけで
たまたま電話が誰からかかかってきても
これをスイッチオンにして電話を受けようと思っちゃうと
もう切られているんですね
それぐらい遅いんですね
しかし 携帯で人生すべてやっている人々もいますよ
友達の関係であろうが
メモを書くとか 時々ネットで見ると
まあなんかいつでも携帯で使うんですね
何かデータとか何か喋る時でも
ちょっと待ってくれ 携帯からこういうことこういうことやとか言ったりする
ある番組で突然 あんたこの歌どうです？歌ってみたら？とかね
みんなに勉強になりますよと言ったら
ああ そうですね 覚えてない
ちょっと待ってくださいとか言ったら
さっさとリリックスだって歌ってる
えらい便利な道具だなと
で 私は俺はもっといいものを持ってるんだけど
まるっきりダメだなとかね
だからそちら使ってる携帯よりは APPLE の IPHONE 持ってますけどね
まるっきりダメですね
だから 業は業なんですけど
人にはその業を幸福になるように使える
あるいははちゃめちゃダメになるように使う
どちらでもできます 業は助けてくれる
大丈夫です 皆様方 これから銀行強盗でも考えているならば
大丈夫 皆様の業がそこをやらせてくれるのでやってくださいと
でも電池 が切れたら途中で中断する羽目になります
だから 業で生まれたからといってね
生き方学ばないと 何に使うかわからない
テロリストも まあ携帯でネットで連絡し合ってテロ行為をやっている
人を非難 侮辱して自殺に追い込むことでもできます
携帯で 昔みたいに苦労する必要はないんです
メッセージ送りまくっちゃえば
相手が自殺してしまいます
どうしようもなくて ブラックメールすることもデータがなくても大丈夫
昔は人をブラックメールする場合は
脅迫する場合はデータが必要なんだよ
あなたのファイル持ってますよとかね
今はそれはいいんです
事実でなくてもいいんです
あんたはああいうところでこういうことをやっています
写真がありますよとかね
その場所で撮った写真にこの写真を埋め込め
フォトショピングというんで
今英語の普通の単語になってますよ
フォトショップというのはただ商品名ですけどね
あれ普通の名詞と動詞になってるんです
だからフォトショピングして
まあまあそれで終わり
面白いことは 法律は人間のためにあるって
あれ法律で裁けないんですね
嘘いて人を撃ったらすごい法律違反なんですけど
ああいう世界は法律の管轄外みたい
はい そういうことを私が言いたいのは
自分持っている機械をどう使うのかと学ばなくちゃいけないんですね
だから我々人間で生まれたら
自分の業をどのように使うべきかと
で 学ばなくちゃいけないんですね
だから生まれてきた人間には
ものすごい素晴らしい人間になって
解脱に達して聖者で死ぬこともできるし
ビンラディンみたいな人間になって死ぬこともできます
どちらでもオープンなんです
あるいは麻薬中毒で どこかでもうもうそのまま心臓発作を起こして
街中でどこかで死んでいる人間になることもできます
億万長者になるかホームレスになるかと
君 決めてくださいと 私は電池は大丈夫だと
どちらにしたっても だからそれは業なんですね
だから覚えてください
呼吸することも 業の電池がなければ動かない
心臓鼓動も業がやってくれないとできません
だから電池切れちゃうとね
先に心臓がいかれちゃうってことはありますよ
電池の使い方は悪くなっちゃうとね
肝臓 腎臓 至るところでがん細胞起きたりする可能性もあります
だから業を正しく使わなくちゃいけない
ここで仏教のポイントは
業の正しい使い方だけではなくて
誰生きても充電の仕方がわからないんです
これが問題なんです 電池がついてますけど
充電セットは持ってこないんです
それが仏教が教えているんです
ブッダに出会っちゃえば
充電セットもらうんです
これって至って簡単な仏教の至って単純なところですね
まずブッダに出会って話しちゃうと
まず君の電池をね 充電しなさいと
そこを教えてあげるんです
それはお釈迦様の目的でも何でもないんです
それってくだらないと言うんです
あんたいくら充電したってもね
あの体壊れますよと 死にますよと
例えば携帯でもね 充電したからといって
携帯の寿命が終わったら壊れるでしょうに
はい それでも我々の業という電池をね
充電しなくちゃいけないね
これ 充電する仕方っていうのは
なかなか世の中を知らないんですし
で だから使うことの反対やればいいんです
すごい物理的と同じ法則なんですね
我々は生まれたら 生まれた瞬間から周りから取るわ取るわ取るわ取るわ
恐ろしいんですよ 一つの生命が誕生した途端から
周りのものは まあ何といいますか
この 取って取って取って
で 周りが壊れてしまうんですよ
母体にいるちっちゃな生命体は何しますかね
母の体から全部取りたい放題
栄養を取ってるんです
母にはどうすることもできない
あなたにはこれぐらい栄養をあげて
残りは私の分だよと その判断できない
子供は取りたい放題取る
お腹にある胎児が もしあまりにも胎児が栄養を取り過ぎちゃって
母体には維持できなくなったら死んじゃいますし
知らない それはもう関係ない
これ うまくバランス見事に整えているとか
そんな話がないんです
何といいますか チャンスというのはね
どうせ母体胎児ってちっちゃいでしょ？このちっちゃなものにちょっと栄養あげたからといってね
大きい体には別に大丈夫ですよ
耐えられます 耐えられない母親たちもいますよ
妊娠してそれで死んじゃったと
危ないんですよ 皆さんはいいですね
その恐れがないんだからね
でも輪廻転生すると分かりませんよ
男は女で生まれる 女は男で生まれていろいろ回転しますからね
だから生まれた生命が吸血鬼みたいな
この言葉忘れてたんです
吸血鬼みたいな感じで
もう周りから取るわ取るわ取るわ取るわ
取って取って取って取って自分を成長する
それで自分の業の電気がどんどん使い使いまくっているんです
取る分は電気がなくなるんです
命がやばい状態になります
それで人間ってアホだからね
生まれたらね えらい世界制覇したくなるでしょ？億万長者になりたいとかね
有名人になりたいとかね
あれやこれやとか 誰だって何かの方法で世界制覇したいんですね
できますよ 別に 同時にあなたの寿命はそれで終わりということになるんです
だから 例えば人気のタレントさんなんかに
日本人はそんな程度でしょ
考えてる夢は 偉そうに私に悪口言って
私は夢ダメと言ってるでしょ
我々は夢を持ってありがたく生きて
夢なんなの？ってくだらなくてしょうがないんです
そんな夢だったら捨てろと言いたいんですね
もう人気者になることは
タレントさんになることとかね
アホアホくさくて ね まあ若いスポーツマンたちはね
何としてでもオリンピックに出たい
メダル取りたいっていうのは
まあそれはそれでいいよ
頑張ってくださいって気持ちになるんだけど
みんなの夢聞いたらアホくさくて
たまらないんですね はい
とにかくこの自分が作った夢にはたどりますけど
すべて電池は消えてしまうんですね
それで それからその人にはろくな人生はできませんね
ただなんとなく亡骸みたいな感じで生きている羽目になるんです
だからもう有名タレントになっちゃうと
全く自分 人間っていうことはもう死んで亡骸だけなんですよ
みんな言う通りに操られて
あちらへ行ってこちらへ行って
決まった言葉を喋って
決まった仕草をして 決まったところで決まったご飯を食って
決まった時間 寝る時間もないんですけど
あの連中には 本当にこれって人間かい？と思えるほどの変な生き方をするんですよ
しかし 我々バカとは人気者だから
舞台に出てくるまで待っていて
ガーッとやってね 来た来た
それは猿が来てね まあそういうやることやって
それ出ていて それから次のところに行くという
自分の人生がなくなる
猿になるんです あの安倍首相にしたっても
まあ総理大臣まで自分の夢を叶ったんですけど
それで人間であることまで終わっちゃってるんです
はい これからあなたはただの猿やと
ただのロボットやと それから終わり
ただのロボット 総理職を辞めたからといって真面目な人生はできません
それからは だから電池では何にも使える
極悪犯罪者になることもできる
相当能力は必要ですよ
犯罪者になるためにも
だから皆様みたいにね
まあ善人でもないし 悪人でもないし
どこでもないでしょ？だから能力ないって話なんですけどね
能力あったらどちらにしますけどね
だからこの悪いことをする人々は相当能力はありますよ
しかし 何か何か悪いことをして悪人やと決定になったところからロボットなんですね
終わり 残りはロボットからだけで
生活しなくちゃいけないんです
というわけで 自分が達する目的はね
80年  85年経ってやっと叶いますと言った方がいいんで
だって生きてるんだからさ
80  85年間も で そこでもののけになってしまっちゃうんですね
だからみんなくだらん目的設定して
このくだらん目的にアホ臭い目的に達しちゃって威張っちゃうでしょ
それで人間の気が全部抜けちゃってから
そういう人々に何か仏教を教えたっても理解できないんです
例えば 誰かが弁護士になることを夢だと思ったらね
なんか弁護士試験合格して
インターン終わった時点で終わり
それから人の話は聞けません
聞いても理解できない
それからロボットであれやっているだけ
それが人生だ だから人生
その悲しいサイクルをね
お釈迦様が直す方法を教えてるんですよ
それで 充電する方法ですからね
充電するっていう方法の 第1は
吸血を一旦やめてくださいなんです
吸血鬼でね もうもうすっわすっわ生命からもう視線からもうもう吸って吸って吸いまくって生きようとする
ちょっとそれやめてみてください
やめて逆な行為やってみてくださいと
それ充電しましょうと
だからそのステップの 第1は布施なんです
奪う 奪う 奪う 生命でしょ
ちょっとやめて休んであげる
あげることにしてくださいと
で ものすごい充電するんで
自分の電池は だから善行為してね
業って良い業を満たすっていうことが仏教が教えてるんですね
そこで電池使うちゃうと
これネガティブエネルギーが生まれるんですね
それは悪行為というんですよ
だから電池そのものに
業そのものに ポジティブ的に働くエネルギーもあって
ネガティブ的に働いて
不幸 不幸 不幸 いわゆる目的に達せられる働きもあって
目的は粉々に壊れて壊れて壊れて
どんどん落ち込んで不幸になるというふうな働きもあります
だから自分持っている電池はどのように働くかということはよくわかりません
だから 業には善悪 2つあります
どうしても悪業っていうのはもう決して良くないんですね
いつでも希望の反対に行くんですよ
美しくなりたいと思ったら
直ちに醜くなる 長生きしたいと思った途端
直ちに短命になる 健康でいたいと思ったら
すぐ健康が壊れて なくなっちゃう
だから皆様にもあるでしょうね
いろいろ期待希望あったんだけど
結果見たら反対ですと
あの場合はマイナス業が働いているんですね
ポジティブ業が働いちゃうと
希望通りになる 美しくなりたかった
美しくなりましたと 健康になりたかった
今私は健康ですとというふうに言える場合は
エネルギーがポジティブに働いているんです
健康になりたがって頑張ったのにと言っちゃうと
その人に働いていたのはネガティブエネルギーなんです
東大に入りたい 入りたかったのに明治で終わっちゃったとというと
ネガティブエネルギーが働いているんです
もう一人が 私は小学校の時からもね
東大に入るそうと決めていたよと
と東大生が言うならば
その人の場合はポジティブエネルギーが働いているんです
そういうことを言ったら
皆様には自分の業の計算の仕方なんです
他人にできない だから自分自身で
今電卓でしたっけ？あれはカリキュレーターは日本語で電卓を挙げたんだから計算してみてください
自分の業をどのように計算するのかと
そこで赤字もう黒字とか出るかもしれませんだけど
その問題をどう解決するのか
これから仏教の話になるんですね
だからブッダが取ることの代わりにあげるということをしなさい
それで我々はいつでもわがままで自我を張るでしょ
これでネガティブエネルギーになるんですね
自我っていいんですよ
別に 俺様 俺様 俺様やった感じで
どうぞ勝手にやってください
誰も何も言いません しかし
本人がずっとネガティブエネルギーを作って作って作って作って
ネガティブ方向には行く
その人はものすごくこの奪う吸血の性格はものすごく強烈なんですよ
みんな自我を張るのは嫌がるのは
ブッダの話を知っているからじゃないんです
自我を張る人は周りに迷惑でしょ
周りのエネルギー全部吸い取られるでしょ
自分の暇取っちゃうでしょ
例えばわがままな人はもう 7時半にお風呂に入りたい
入ってたんだからお風呂入れてくださいと
自分で入れたら自分で入れなさいって言ったら
こいつはわがままだからね
怒鳴るんですね 怒るんですね
なんで？お前の仕事ではなく
お風呂にお湯を張るのは？とかね
そこではいはいと言ってお風呂は入れてあげますけど
自分からあまりにも取っちゃったんですね
あまりにもエネルギーを吸ってしまったんです
だから我々はわがままな人は嫌いですよ
ブッダの教えをわかっているからじゃないんです
わがままな連中がいれば
もう周りから全部吸収しちゃうんですね
周りの生命エネルギーを
回らない自由 回らない幸福
何でも取っちゃう だからそれで自分自身の電池はどうなる？ポジティブ電池全部使っているんだからね
どんどんネガティブ 力が恐ろしく増えるんですね
だからお釈迦様がこのポジティブエネルギーを作るために
わがまま張らないで 人に優しくしなさい
生命はあなたと同じ平等であると思いなさい
慈しみを育てなさい 人を助けなさい
優しい人間になりなさいとかね
夢叶うまで頑張りなさいではないんです
これやってくださいと
夢なんかあってもなくてもどうでもいいで
ポジティブエネルギー満たしてるんだから
だからこのどうでもいい項目に引っかかる必要はないんです
やるやることは成功するんです
期待があってもなくても
だから我々人間っていうのは
嫉妬しないで 生命を慈しんで
生命を憐れんで 自分が偉いと思わないで
誰だって同じ生命やと思って
喧嘩するのは犬猫にもできるんだから
私は喧嘩しませんよと
怒るのは犬猫にもできるんだから
私はだから怒らないようにするぞと
嫉妬するのはどんな馬鹿にもできるんだから
私は一人で嫉妬しないようにするぞと
そういうふうにブッダが教えたリストありますから
そのリストに従って生活すれば
ものすごい素晴らしく生きられます
で そういうふうに この本当に命の真理を発見したからこそ
ブッダを尊敬するべき存在になっているんですね
師匠を尊敬しなきゃ 師匠の教えは体に入りません
そういうことで どんな人間でもすごく頑張って
ウェーサーカ祭などなどをやっています
今日の法要にしたっても
私はすごく気をつけて
この功徳が純粋できれいで
何倍も増えて それから不動で強力な功徳になるようにという条件があるんです
だから今布施行をやったんですけども
大したことないよ もう食べるものあげることだから
もう食べ物は溢れている世界だからね
そんなのどうったことはないんです
たくさん食べ物あったからといってね
胃袋 1個しかないんだからね
食べるのはほんのちょっとだけでしょうし
それって大したことはないんですよ
しかし そこでいろんな条件があって
サンガが来て 個人ではなく
ブッダの聖なるサンガ組織にお布施するということになって
これは個人が個人にご飯を食わせていることではなくて
仏法僧という大阿羅漢たちに
サンガにお布施をする
食べさせていることじゃないんです
尊敬している それも清らかな心で
まず だから五戒をまず受けて
道徳的な人間になって
そうすると恐ろしく功徳が
言いますか 拡大します
拡大というか これ量が増えるんですね
何枚何枚も重ねたことになります
頑丈になるんです 薄い紙だったらすぐ破れますけどもね
同じ薄い紙もね  1万枚ぐらい一緒になっちゃうと破れませんね
だから号っていうのは
そうやってこの層を重ねて重ねていくために
五戒を守って それからその上
慈悲の瞑想をして慈悲の瞑想をすると
その人はこの世に生きる権利を持っている唯一な人間なんです
我々は借金で生きている
借りで生きている 慈悲の気持ちで生きているならば
その人の借金はチャラになっている
そういう慈悲の瞑想をして
そういう先行せまったから
皆様にはものすごい多大な功徳になりましたと思います
でお釈迦様のお誕生日ですけど
得するのお釈迦様ではなくて
それを参加する我々はなんですね
だからブッダの誕生日は普通の人間の誕生日と違いますね
普通の誕生日だったら
誕生日になっているバカだけが得するんですね
プレゼントもらったり
それでおいしくないケーキ食ったり
その人だけスターになっちゃうんですね
ブッダの誕生日はそうじゃないんです
ブッダにはそんなの関係ない
いらない 興味もない 逆にくだらんことをやるなよと怒られる程度
しかし 私たちのわがままで
私たちはウェーサーカ祭りをやって
皆様もね 私はこの仕切りをしたくないんだけどね
あまり意味がないんだけど
でも皆様方 いろんなところに行って
スリランカ人がウェーサーカ祭りどうやっているのかで
よく調べて研究して もうしっかりと間違っているところは正しく学んで
こちらへ正しく再現しようとはしているんです
だからウェーサーカ祭り
正しくやりたければ  1 日中瞑想すればいいんです
仏像の前で あ お釈迦様のお誕生日だから
今日は朝から晩までほんのちょっと何か食べて
ちょっと何か水で何かちょっと飲んで
1 日中ブッダの世界に入っているんだよということで瞑想すれば
それに匹敵できる まあそれはないんですけど
それはやりたくないんで
まあいろいろスリランカ人がやることの真似したいでしょ
あの連中は世界一アホなんですけどね
まあ真似してください
まあとにかく それで皆様とすごくいい気持ちでね
私は頭が悪くて教えてくれないんだからね
いろいろ研究して調べて
食べるものにしたってもね
日本人が食べるものだってもいいんだけど
いろいろ調べて インド的なものをネパール的なものやら
あれやこれやとか持ってきたり
結構頑張ってるでしょうに
だからこれ今日だけじゃないでしょ
かなり前からもうハチャメチャ準備して
で 昨日はね すごく準備しちゃって
私も昨日夜来たんで どうせ十時半まで頑張るだろうと思ってね
みんなからかってやるぞと思って
やる気はとことん壊してやるぞと思って来たんですけど
私は来る時はみんな仕事終わって帰っていたんですね
みんな帰ってきた  そういうことで
皆様方はものすごく長い間いろいろ研究して準備して
ものすごい苦労してお釈迦様のお誕生日をやって
まあこれはまあ前半はこれで終了になりますね
しかし 私はどんな悪口言っても
皆様方は素直にブッダのためにやっていることなんです
私は悪魔役でとにかくこれ壊してやれる方法ないのかと考えてるだけなんですね
でもそれで皆様方 すごく素直に真面目で頑張ってるんだから
もうどんな台風にもどんな竜巻にも揺れない素晴らしい善行為を持っているはずなんです
だから この功徳の力というのを正しくやれば
その場で結果が出てきます
私は心配しているのは
この条件そろって正しく功徳をさせようと思っているんですよ
結構難しいんですね それでお互い様の関係も必要だし
心の関係もあるし どこかで条件ちょっとずれちゃうんですね
出る問題なんですよ だけど
それでも今日もね ほとんど条件そろってよく功徳を積まったので
まあ今からいろいろいいこと並べてくると
もう連続してくると思います
それだけではなくて 皆様
この功徳によってね 我々にはこの幸福っていうのはくだらん
いい家があったっても面倒くさいでしょ
頭のいい子供が 3人いるんだと言ったら
えらい面倒くさいで そうしたら面倒見なくちゃいかんだから
自分の旦那の仕事の格がすごくゴーンと上がっちゃってね
副社長になったぞと思ったら
奥さんにとっては地獄なんで
それからそれに合わせて猿まねしなくちゃいかんでしょう
金持ちの間でニコニコと笑って
またいろんな服を買って
だから世の中の幸福っていうのはもう最低くだらないんですよ
自分を猿にさせるだけ
総理大臣という猿 猿 文部大臣という猿
猿たちですよ 人間で生活できなくなっちゃうんです
人間というのは まあ幼稚園の時だけなんですね
そういうわけで この世の中の幸福とかね
成功とかね そんな排泄物はどうでもいいんです
我々は怒りなく 嫉妬なく
憎しみなく 欲がない 無明のない
煩悩のない心を作りましょうと
一切の執着をなくして
この功徳の力で涅槃解脱に達することができますようにとプログラミングしてください
どこかで私は言ったでしょう
業のプログラミングしましょうとかね
テーラワーダ仏教の人々
だから皆様も自分の業を輪廻までプログラミングしていく
それは誓願というんですね
ですから皆様方 我々は今
獲得した無料の功徳によって
完全たる解脱涅槃に達せられますようにと
サードゥサードゥサードゥじゃ
サードゥサードゥサードゥ
サマンタチャッカレースーアッラーガッチャンとデーヴァタサッダマンムニラージャッサスナントーサッカモッカダン
ダンマサワダカーロアヤンバダンタダンマサワダカーロアヤンバダンタパリッタダンマサワダカーロアヤンバダンタ
ナモタッセ バガヴァトーワレハトーサッマサンブッダッセ
イティピソーバガワーアランサッマサンブッダ
ヴィッジャシャラナサンパンノウサガトーローカヴィトゥ
タロー ブリス ダンマ サーラティ
サッターデーヴァ マヌッサナン
ブッドー バガヴァーティ
スワッカーロー バガヴァター
ダンモ サンディッティコー
アカーリコー イパッシコー
ウパナイコー パッチャッタン
ウェーディ タッボー インヨー
イーティ スッパティ パッモー
バガヴァトー サーヴァカサンゴー
ウジュパティ パッモー
ニャーヤパティ パッモー
バガヴァトー サーヴァカサンゴー
サーミージ パティ パッモー
アティダン チャッサーリ
プリサ ユガーニ アッタ
プリサ プッガラ エーサ
バガヴァトー サーヴァカサンゴー
アウネイヨー バウネイヨー
ダッキネイヨー アンジャリ
カラネイヨー アヌッタラン
プンナッキッタン ローカッサーティ
エーテーナ サッチャ ワッジェーナ
パートゥタン ラタナッタヤン
エーワンメ シュタン エータン
サマヤン バガヴァー サーヴァッティヤン
ウィヤラティ ジェータワネ
アナータピンディカッサ
アーラーメ アタゴー アンニャ
タラー デーヴァター ヴィッカンターヤ
アッティヤー アビッカンタ
ワンナー ケーワラカッパン
ジェータワナン オーバー
セッサーエーナ バガヴァーティ
ヌパサン カミン ヌパサン
カミットワー バガワン
タング アビワーデッラー
エーカマン タング アッターティ
エーカマン タング ティター
ゴーサー デーヴァター
バガワン タング アッターヤ
アッジャ バージー バホー
デーヴァー マヌッサ ジャヤ
マンガラーニ チンタヨン
アーカン カーマーナー
ソッターナン ホーイ マンガラ
ムッタマン アセーヴァナー
チャ バーラーナン パンディターナン
チャ セーヴァナー プーージャー
チャ プージャニーヤーナン
エータン マンガラ ムッタマン
パティ ルーパ デーサ ワースー
チャ プンベーサ カタ プンニャター
アッタ サッマー パニディ
チャ エータン マンガラ
ムッタマン バーホー サッチャン
チャ シッパン チャ ウィナヨー
チャ スシッキットー スーバー
シッター チャ アー- アヴァジャエタン マンガラ ムッタマーン マター ピトー パッターナン プッタダ
ーラッサ サンガホー アナークーラーチャ カンマンター エタン マンガラ ムッタマンガーナンチャ ダンマ
チャリヤーチャ ナータカーナンチャ サンガホー アナヴァッジャーニ カンマーニー エタン マンガラ ムッタ
マン アーラティ ヴィラティ パーパ マッジャパーナーチャ サンニャモー アッパマー ドーチャ ダンメスー エタン
マンガラ ムッタマン カーラ ドーチャ ニワットーチャ サントゥッティーチャ カタンニュターカーレーナ ダンマサヴァナ
ン エタン マンガラ ムッタマン カンティーチャ ドーヴァジャッサター サマナーナンチャ ダッサ
ナン カーレーナ ダンマサーカッチャー エタン マンガラ ムッタマン タポチャ ブラフマチャリヤンチャ アリ
ーヤ サッチャーナ ダッサナン ニッバーナ サッチキリヤーチャ エタン マンガラ ムッタマン プッタッサ ローカ
ダンメヒ チッタン ヤン サナカン パティー アトー タム ヴィラジャン ケマン エタン マンガラ ムッ
タマン エターディサーニ カッターナ サッバッタ マパラジター サッバッタ ソッティン アッチャンティ タン
テー サン マンガラ ムッタマン テーテーナ サッチャワッジェーナ ホートゥ テー ジャヤマンガラン テーナ サッチャワッ
ジェーナ ホートゥ テー ジャヤマンガラン エーテーナ サッチャワッジェーナ ホートゥ テー ジャヤマンガラー
ニ イダ ブーターニ サマーガターニ ブンマーニ ワラーニ ワアンカニッケ サッベーワ ブーター クマナー バヴァントゥ
アトーピ サンカッチャ スナントゥ パーシタン タスマーヒ ブーターニ サメッタ サッベー メッサン カロータ
マヌシア パージャーヤ ヴィワッチャ ラットーチャ アランティ ヘーバリン タスマーヒ ネーラッカタ アッパマッター
キンチッ ヴィッタン イダ ワーウラン ワーサンヴェー スーアーヤン ラタナン パニータン アノー サマン アッティ
タターガテーナ イダンピ ブッデー ラタナン パニータン エテーナ サッチェーナ スワッティ ホートゥ カヤン
ヴィラーカン アマタン パニータン ヤダッジャカー サッキャ ムニー サマーヒトーナテーナ ダンメーナ サマン
ティ キンチ イダンピ ダンメー ラタナン パニータン エテーナ サッジェーナ スワッティ ホートゥ アン プッタセット
ー パリワンナヒ スチーン サマーディ マーナン タリカッニャ マーウー サマーディナーデーナ サモーナ ヴィッジャティ
ー イダンピ ダンメー ラタナン パニータン エテーナ サッジェーナ スワッティ ホートゥ エー ブッガラ
アッタ サタン パサッター ジャッターリ エターニ ヨガーニ アンティー テー タッキネーヤー スガタントー サーヴァカー
エテー スディンナーニ マッパラニー イダンピ サンゲー ラタナン パニータン エテーナ サッジェーナ ス
ワッティ ホートゥ エー スッパヨッター マナサー ダッレーナー ニッカー ミノーロー ダマサーサナン ニーデ
ー パッティ パッター マタン ヴィガイヤ ランダー ムダーニ ブッディン ブンジャマーノー イダンピ サンゲ
ー ラタナン パニータン エテーナ サッジェーナ スワッティ ホートゥ ヤティン ワキーロー パタヴィン シト
ゥー シヤー チャトゥン ピワーデービ アサン パカン ピヨー タトゥーパ マングァ プーリ サンワダー ミーヨ
ー アリーヤ サッチャーニ アレッチャ パッサティー ダンピ サンゲー ラタナン パニータン エテーナ サッジェーナ
スワッティ ホートゥ エー アリーヤ サッチャーニ ヴィバーワ アンティー ガンビーラ パンテーナン ウデーシ
ターニ キンチャーピ テーワンディプ サッバ マッターナテー
アッ
タマンアーディアンティーダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッテーナスワッティホートゥーサーヴァッサダッサナサンパダータースダンマージャイター
パワンティーサッカーヤディッティチキッチタンチャシーラッパタンマービアダッチキッチチャトゥーバーイイタヴィップモットーサチャーヴィターナーニアパッボー
ガトゥンダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッテーナスワッティホートゥーキンチャーピソーカンマンカロティパーパカンカーエーナワーチャーウタジェ
ータサーワーパッボーソータッサパティッチャダーヤアバッバターディッタパダッサホッターイダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッテーナスワッティホー
トゥーアナッパグンベーアタープッシダンゲーキンマナマーセパタマッスミンキンメータドゥーパマンダンマワランアデーサイニッバーナダーミンパラマンイターイダン
ピブッデーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッテーナスワッティホートゥーワローワランノーワラトーワラーワローアヌッタローダンマワランアデーサイイダンピブッ
デーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッテーナスワッティホートゥーキーナンパーラーナンナワンアッティサンバワンウィラッタチッターヤティケーバワッスミンテーケ
ーナビーチャーウィルッリンチャンダーニッバンティティーラーアターナンパディーポーイダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッテーナスワッティホートゥ
ーヤーニイダブーターニサマーガターニブッマーニワーヤーニワアンカリッケータターガタングデーヴァマヌッサプージタングブッダンナマッサマスワッティホートゥ
ーヤーニイダブーターニサマーガターニブッマーニワーヤーニワアンカリッケータターガタングデーヴァマヌッサプージタングダンマッナンナマッサマスワッティホー
トゥーヤーニイダブーターニサマーガターニブッマーニワーヤーニワアンカリッケータターガタングデーヴァマヌッサプージタングサンガンナマッサマスワッティホー
トゥーエーテーナサッチャワッジェーナドゥッカウーパサミントゥテーエーテーナサッチャワッジェーナバーウーパサミントゥテーエーテーナサッチャワッジェーナロー
ガーウーパサミントゥテーカラーニーヤマッタクサレーナヤンタンサンタンパタンアビサメッチャサッコジョーチャソー
スーワローナッサ ムドゥ アナティマニ サンゴッサ ゴーチャ スーパローチャ アッパキッチョーチャ サ
ッラ ウカブッティ サンティンドリヨーチャ ニパコーチャ アッパ カッボー クレースー アナヌディッドー
ナチャ クッタン サマチャレー キンチエーナ ミンノー パレー パワディヨング スキノーワーケー ビノーン
トゥ サッベ サッター バヴァントゥ スキタッター エケーチ パーナブー タッティー タサーワ
ー ターワラーワー アナワセーサーティーガーワー エーマーンターワー マッジマーラッサカーヌカ トーラー ディッタ
ーワー エーワ アッディッター エーチャ ドゥーレーワ サンティ アビドゥーレー ブーターワー サンバヴェーシーワ
ー サッベ サッター バヴァントゥ スキタッター ナパロー パラン ミクン ベータナーティ マンエータ
カンタチナン カンチー ギャーローサナー パティガサンニャーナーニャ マンニャッサ ドゥッカ ミッチェーヤ マーターター
ニ ヤン プッタン アユサーエーカ プッタ マヌランケー ワンプ サッバ ブーテー スーマナ サンバーヴェー アパリマーナン
メッタンチャ サッバロー カッミー マナ サンバーヴェー アパリマーナン オッタン アドーチャ シリヤンチャ
バダン アヴェーラン アサパッタン ティッタン チャラン ニシンノーワー サヤーノーワーヤーワ タッサ ヴィカタ
ヴィッドー エータン サティン アディッテーヤ ブラフマ メータン ヴィハラン イタマホー ディッティンチャ アヌパ カ
мма シーラワー タッサネーナ サンパンノーカー メー スウィネイアケー ダンナイラー トゥ ガッバ セイヤン
プナレーティーティー テーナ サッチャワンジェーナ ソッティデー ホートゥ サッバダーエー テーナ サッチャワンジェー
ナ ソッティデー ホートゥ サッバダーエー テーナ サッチャワンジェーナ ソッティデー ホートゥ サッバダー サンマン
カロ マハーヴィーロ メダンカロ マーヤソー パラナンカロ ローカイトー ディーバンカロ ドゥッティンガロー コンダンニョー
ジャナバー モッコ マンガロー プリターサポー スマノー スマノー ディーロー レーワトー ラティ
ワッダノー ヴィトー グナサンパンノー アノー マダッシー ジャヌットーモー パドモー ローカパッニョートーナーラトー
アラサーラティー パドモッターロー ナッタサーロー スメトー アッガポッンガロー スージャトー サッバ
ロー カンゴー ピヤダッシーナーラー サポー アッタダッシー カーロニコ ダンマダッシー タモーヌトー シッダットー
アサモー ローケー ディッソー アラダ サンワロー プッソー アラダ サンブッドー ヴィパッシーチャ アヌーパモー
ディキー サッバ イトー サッター ヴェッサポー スカターヤーコー カクサンノー サッタワーロー コーナーガ
マノーラ ナンジャウー カッサポー シリサンパンノー ゴーダモー サッキャ ポンガロー テー サッチャワンジェーナ
シーレーナ カンティ メッタ バレーナ チャテーピタング アヌラッカントー アローゲーナ スケーナ ジャーティ
ー マー カーロニコ ナートー イターヤ サッバパーニナング ポーレッター パラミー サッバ パットー サンボーデ
ィ ムッタマング テーナ サッチャワンジェーナ ホートゥ テー ジャヤマンガラン ジャヤントゥ ボディア ムーレー
サッキャナン ナンディ ワッダノー エーワントゥ イヤン ジャヨー ホートゥ ジャヤッス ジャヤマンガラン サッカッタ
ブッダラタナン オーサダン オッタマンワラン イタンデーヴァ マヌッサーナン ブッダテージェーナ ソッティナーナッサン
トゥ パッダワー サッベ ドゥッカ オーパ サミントゥテー サッカッタ ダンマラタナン オーサダン オッタマンワラン
パリラー オーパ サマナン ダンマテージェーナ ソッティナーナッサン トゥ パッダワー サッベ パーラー
オーパ サミントゥテー サッカッタ サンガラタナン オーサダン オッタマンワラン パルネイヤン パウネイヤン サ
ンガテージェーナ ソッティナーナッサン トゥ パッダワー サッベロー
...皆さま方に準備するまで
えーっと 待ち 待たないで始まります
[笑い]で まあ自由に出入りするのは構いません
えっと あの お釈迦様はね
完全に心の煩悩を解かれたんだからね
あまり緊張する必要はないんです
気楽に参加してください
はい これから慈悲の瞑想いたします
この慈悲の瞑想で あの
こういうポイントを理解してください
で 私がいるんですね これは問題の始まりなんですね
私がいるとは 他の生命は他人なんです
すごいでっかい壁が現れるんですね
ですから 私がいないということにしなくちゃいけない
それは順番で言えば  私はいない
私は男でもありません
女でもありません 仏教をやっている仏教徒でもありませんとかね
で 何者でもありませんと
で 私がいる場合は犬がいるんですね
犬と私は同じじゃないんですね
私がいる場合は猫がいるんですね
猫と私が同じじゃないんですね
そこで私は犬とどう付き合えばいいか
猫とどう付き合えばいいかと問題が起こるんです
そこで自分が思った付き合い方は
犬には合わない可能性ありますね
犬が気が立ったと 私の付き合い方が失敗しちゃって
そういうことで あるいは犬の態度を見て
私の気に入らないということにもありますね
だから一切トラブルが私がいるから現れるんです
そこで全てこの被っているもの
犬として被っている肉体はね
猫はある肉体被っていて
こちら人間という肉体被っていて
この被り物を外してみましょう
被り物をすべて外したところで
最終的に残るのは生命なんです
私はではなくて 生命はということになるんです
これは生命だったら犬も生命なんですね
生命だったら同じ平等でしょ
どう付き合えばいいかって問題は消えちゃうんです
この慈悲の瞑想で この生命としての波長にコンタクトできるんです
今 我々の連絡手段はちょっとそうできなくなっているんですね
私という波長で信号を出してますけど
これ誰も受信しません
しかし 私に犬になりきって犬という信号は出せませんね
だから犬とコミュニケーションできなくなっている
それで私が言いたいのは
生命になりましょうよ
みんな犬も猫もミミズもゴキブリも
もうもうカエルさんももうメダカも何でもかんでも
最終的に微生物さえ全て生命であると
その波長に入ってみましょう
この波長に入るためには
この慈悲の瞑想は真剣に唱えてみるとできるようになります
そこでこの被り 外せば外すほど楽なんですよ
例えば ある女の人がお嫁さんの衣装というを被っちゃうと
結構大変でしょ で 日本伝統的なお嫁の服を着ちゃうと
ゆっくり歩かなきゃいけないし
もうだって色々とたくさん着ているんだからね
もう体に背負うないぐらい重いものをね
だからそれに演じなくちゃいけない
自分を殺さなくちゃいけない
そこでそのお嫁さんのその西洋
日本の服を外して 西洋のウェディングドレスを着たら
また違うやり方を演じなくちゃかんでしょ
それでウェディングドレスも外して
普通のワンピース着ていくと
お化粧まで変えなくちゃかんでしょ
日本衣装のお嫁さんのお化粧とウェディングドレスのお嫁さんのお化粧まで違うでしょ
そこで普通の洋服着たら
あのお化粧変でしょ また変えなくちゃいけない
アクセサリーまで これって自己いじめじゃないんですかね？どこまで衣装を被って自分をいじめるんですかね
だから男性方々は男という衣装を被っちゃって
ひどい目にあってるんですよ
女性の方々は女性という衣装を被っちゃって
まあ演じなくちゃあかんですね
まあ私たちみたいにね
変な言葉言ったりとかできんでしょ？できません
できますよ でも衣装に合わせなくちゃね
おばあちゃんだったらね
なんであの少年みたいな言葉遣い
生き方しないんですかね
やっぱりおばあちゃんという被りに合わせて自己管理しなくちゃいけない
しかし おばあちゃんがね
もう歳 の女の子みたいに喋っちゃうと超気持ち悪いんですね
だからそれではなくて
衣装を全部貸して生命になる
そちらみんなつながるんです
この宇宙が現れて 生命が現れている過程で
ある時期で宇宙すべて消えるんです
全く空になるんです この膨大な宇宙が
全部爆破してて まあなくなるんです
で 空になった時点で その時だけ生命に被り物がなくなっちゃうんです
その時だけ生命がまあ一つの次元になるんだそうです
で その時で仏教ではつの次元になるんだと
とても安らぎの次元か
とても暗闇の次元か どちらくなる
暗闇になったらもう暗闇の波動でいる
で 他の生命たちはもっと上の一つの次元になるんだと
そのつの次元でいて それからまた物質的な宇宙が始めてくると
また被り物かぶろうとして
また区別に区別差別世界が現れてくるというのは
仏教の宇宙論の中にある一つのポイントなんですね
だからここで私は言いたいのは
我々は個別の的な生命が現れる以前にあった
この一つの海のような波長のところに戻ってみましょうと
それはすごい気持ちのいい
心清らかになる次元なんです
ジーノー瞑想でそれをやろうとするんです
まあ時間は長くやっちゃ使いますので
まあすごく早くやりましょう
では 第一章私はが幸せでありますように
ご一緒に唱えましょう
私は幸せでありますように
私の心に現れる悩み 苦しみが徐々に消えていきますように
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみの感情は人の心を苦しめます
苦しみである怒り 嫉妬
憎しみが私の心に起こりませんように
怒り 瞋恚と憎しみの妄想を育てないように努めます
私の思考が慈しみの思考になりますように
私は物事が常に変化して消え去るものであると観察します
私は遊び 散った出来事に取らわれないように精進します
私は将来のことに執着して悩まない
不安にならない人間になります
私は今 心でするべきことに集中します
それは慈悲の瞑想をする一つのバージョンですね
次のバージョンは 私に他者に対する慈しみの気持ちが現れますように
他者の壁 他者という壁を破ってみるんですね
私に他者に対する慈しみの気持ちが現れますように
他者に対して優しい心で対応することができますように
私の心に他を差別する気持ちが現れませんように
苦しい状況に遭遇しても
忍耐することができますように
私の心が常に平安でありますように
私の心の汚れが徐々になくなりますように
私にありのままの事実を発見することができますように
私に真理を発見する智慧が現れますように
私に一切の現象に対する愛着がなくなりますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
はい このチャプターで順番に心が成長していく道を書いてありますからね
気持ち理解して唱えれば
自分の智慧が現れてきます
今日は焦ってるんだから早くやります
はい 次 別なテーマ取ります
すべての生命は兄弟であると
もし我々はこの宇宙が現れる以前
一つの生命でいたならば
みんな兄弟でしょ それから個性が現れただけ
似てることはヒンドゥ教でも言ってますね
あのヒンドゥ教では梵天と言うんですね
ブラフマという神 もともと生命はブラフマだけでしたと
それからあのブラフマの魂がバラバラバラバラになっちゃって
森羅万象の世界が現れちゃったと
ですから 同じものだと
あのインドで最近亡くなったね
かなり人気があった宗教家がいたんですね
まあ八十パーセントインチキの方なんですけど
まあ名前を言っていいかどうかよくわかりませんけどもね
サイババさんですね で
サイババはあんまり勉強してきた人ではないんですけど
インド人だから インド教徒としてはまあまあ別に知っていることでね
で 彼がサイババが神そのものであるとみんな拝んでるんですね
だからサイババを神に仕立てるのは一般人なんですよ
だから神だったらいろいろ奇跡も必要でしょ
できないんですね だからいろいろ裏技
マジックを 学んでこれやってるんですね
これだけはなめないんですね
それは今バレバレバレてますね
どうやっていろんなものを現象化したのかどうかね
それはいいんだけどね
しかし 本人が言うのは
私は英語で喋ってるところしか聞こえてないんですけど
皆様が私は神であると思っていますよと
で 私はあなた方は神であると言いました
ユーコールミーゴッド
アイコールユーゴッドという言葉なんですね
ユーアーゴッド あなたは神であると
そうすると ああ 神様はなんとか病気治ってくれてる
あなた神様ですよと言われると
誰も理解しない でもみんなバカだからね
でもこれ哲学的に見ると
これヒンドゥー教哲学に合ってる言葉なんです
だってヒンドゥー教では最初は神という一つの命でした
梵天というブラフマという一個の命でした
この一個の命が分解しちゃって
無数の命になりました
って話なんですね で 彼らがじゃあこの個別の命
魂が神が元の魂につながれば解脱であると
お釈迦様はあのね また分解したらあんたどうするのだと
だからそれは解脱ではないと仏教は語ってるんですね
しかし ポイントは仏教のブッダの智慧で見ても一字はあるんですね
いわゆるあの人ごとわかってないんだけど
お釈迦様はビッグバンのこと
ビッグクランチのことは自分で見ていたんですね
だから世界はあのビッグバンとかね
あって爆発から始まるでしょ
爆発する時点で何もないんです
だから空がいきなり爆発するんだからね
1点が で それから生命が現れるんですね
だから生命エネルギーはそこまで場所が全くない時
どこにいたのかと それは仏教では次元の名前ありますね
なんとか梵天の次元なんですね
そちらは梵天という この梵天の次元で一体の生命がいるんですよ
そこで一体の生命が宇宙が現れてくると
それぞれかぶりものをかぶっちゃっては出ていく
かぶりものをかぶっては出ていく
例えば我々 大きい入れ物で何かあの飲み物
何かジュース作りましょう
リンゴジュースでもミックスジュースでもいいんですね
そこでみんないろんなカップを持ってきて
紙カップやら色をつけたカップやらガラスやらね
あるいは飯入れる茶碗やら何でもいい
それぞれに入れてもらっちゃうと
そこで個別的な存在になるんですね
ですから この慈悲の瞑想で我々やるのは
このあの波長にコミュニケーションを取ることなんですね
みんな一緒になった時の波長に
ですから すべての生命は兄弟っていうところで始まります
私はすべての生命が私の兄弟であると思えるように精進します
私はすべての生命と私が平等であると思えるように精進します
私はすべての生命の幸福と繁栄を
を期待します 私は生命の間で調和が保たれるように精進します
というところで もう一つやり方を思い出しましたけど
ただどこかで電車に乗っていると
誰かを狙ってみる 知らない人をね
狙ってみて その人を対象にして
この人は私の兄弟である
例えばちょっと年上の女性役としましょう
あ これは私の姉ちゃんです
姉ちゃんが元気で楽しく幸せでいてほしい
はい 年下の女の子 あ この人を狙うと
これは私の妹ですと はい
妹ちゃんも元気でね そこでこの区別する心が分かります
もう初めて見た人には姉ちゃんという気持ちが生まれないでしょ
あの生まれないとこも感じてください
それは自分の差別心なんですね
例えば電車だったらおじいちゃんがいる
変なじじいやと思わないで
あ このおじいさんが私のお父さんです
私のお父さんです お父さん
どうか元気で仲良くしてほしいと
そうすると お父さんと思えない自分にも気づきますね
あれは自分で直すところなんですね
だからその変なところも感じつつ
ちょっとやってみてください
見事に成長してしまいます
はい 次に行きます 釈尊の言葉を念じて言います
私は釈尊の言葉を念じます
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の母ではなかった生命ははいません
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の父ではなかった生命はいません
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の兄弟ではなかった生命はいません
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の子供ではなかった生命はいません
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の友人ではなかった生命はいません
釈尊の戒めを尊んで 一切の生命に慈しみの気持ちを抱きます
すべての生命は私自身の父母であると思います
すべての生命は私自身の兄弟であると思います
すべての生命は私自身の子供であると思います
すべての生命は私自身の友人であると思います
すべての生命は私自身の家族であると思います
すべての生命は幸福でありますように
はい  このセクションはすごくわかりやすい
ブッダの言葉そのままなんですね
それから実践する方法
はい 次のチャプターに行きます
で この場合は 例えを使って
自分の心はどうやって無常のかかっていると理解する方法なんで
これも経典にある引用から
お釈迦様とサーリプッタ尊者の言葉から借りて作ったものなんです
心は空気のように 空気と空気が何の対立性もなく一体になるように
私の慈しみの気持ちがすべての生命の心と一体になりますように
水と水が何の対立性もなく一体になるように
太陽の光が地球の隅から隅まで照らしますよ
照らすように 私の慈しみの光がすべての生命の心を妨げなく照らせるように
制限なく慈しみを育みます
東西南北上下という六方十方の生命
対して無限心どどまることなく慈しみを育みます
ということで まあわかりやすいんですね
次に行きましょうか 心は大事のように
まあこれはちょっと勉強した方がいいですね
この大地っていうのは私たちの母でしょ
大地のものを食べているでしょ
大地の上に住んでいるでしょ
この肉体は大地がくれたものでしょ
完全に大地が作り出した命なんですね
太陽のエネルギーは活動するためには使っていますけど
活動するための物体は大地がくれますからね
我々が食べるジャガイモ
食べるサツマイモ 誰が作ってますかね？大地が作っているんですね
飛行機に乗って行っても大地にいるんです
大地から逃げられません
重力があるんですからね
だから飛行機は空気を流して飛ばしているでしょ
地球に引っ張られてないと飛ばせません
もし地球のあれ 重力が消えた途端
飛行機はどうなることかと
大変なことになります
ですから 我々はすべて大地のお世話のおかげで
大地にいただいて命を保っていてくれる
しかし 我々の態度はどうですかね
破壊したい放題破壊する
大地が生み出す他の生命は残酷に壊す
考えてください 兄貴が弟を殺しちゃうと
お母さんどんな気持ちになる？兄貴が弟をくったくたに殴って怪我させて骨を壊していると
これ見てる母どうしますかね
こいつも私の息子で こいつも私の息子で
だから母にできますか？この弟
兄貴をね てめえ殺ってやれ
ぶん殴ってやれ できないでしょ
自分が産んだ子供だから
でもやられているのは自分の子どもなんだよ
そこのこのイメージ考えてください
この母のあの心は  実際そういうことはないかもしれませんだけどね
だから私たちは平気で植物を壊すわ
いじめるわ 迷惑かけるわ
他の生命は平気で殺しまくるわ
破壊しまくるわ それは大地はどうやって
しかし 大地は不動で 誰の味方も取らないで平等にいるんです
そこで地球を破壊する原子爆弾を作るでしょ
原子爆弾はうまく働くかないかと実験するために
どこで実験を行いますかね
大地の中に穴を掘って爆破させてみるんです
目的は大地を壊しちゃいたいんです
原子爆弾ガラガラガラと爆発したらもう地球終わりでしょ
そこでも私たちは大地がくれたジャガイモとご飯とかね
もういろいろ食べて出す場合はどこに出す？それの母の体に上に出すんですね
そこで この大地のそのイメージを
我々はあなたの心にして
慈悲の心にしてください
この世の中で生きていると
お前バカやと言う人間はいくらでもいますよ
お前アホやという人はいくらでもいる
あなたの顔二度と見たくないという人もいるんですね
あなたのことを何と死ぬまで恨んでやるぞという人もいるんです
私にはいるんだけどね
で しかし あなた大地になってください
あなたは大地になってください
あんた馬鹿やってすみませんねと
悪かったねとね あなたに迷惑かけて
たとえ 自分を殺そうとする
その時も大地の心を持たなければいけない
大地に原子爆弾を突きようと思っても
大地は反抗しませんね
どうぞやってください
本当の慈悲がある人は
自分を殺そうとする人にも
あんた幸せになってね
まあ殺してもあの できることなら捕まされないように気をつけてください
という風に言葉を変える人間になってください
それは慈悲なんです 冗談じゃないんで
慈悲っていうのは ちょっとしたお遊びじゃないんです
皆様 会社で上司にちょっと叱られただけで
精神的にストレスかかっちゃって病気になるでしょ
会社で時々仕事の能力が
自分の能力が下がっちゃうと
これで落ち込んじゃってうつになるでしょ
大地の心だったらね 何のこともないんです
何のことはないんです
だから あの人が悪い この人が悪い
あの人のせいで私はもうもう苦しんでいる
あの人のせいで私は不幸になっているってことは消えるでしょ
大地の心になったら お前のせいで私は不幸じゃなくて
人が自分を殺そうとする時でもね
お前のせいで私は殺される羽目になったないんですから
どうぞあなたは幸せになってください
というところのところまで
この気持ちを育ててほしいですね
ですから この大地の例えが仏教で使ってます
それはもうあえてサーリプッタ尊者がよく使った
自分の心の状況を発表する時は
この大地の例えを言ってるんですね
自分が大地のようにいるんだよと
誰かさんがね ちょっと悪口言ったからといって
ちょっと非難したからといって
で そういうそういう人は幸福になってほしい
そういう気持ちでいるんですよ
はい 大地のように始まります
私の心は大地の様に大地はいかなる清らかなものを捨てても
いかなる不浄なものを捨てても
喜ぶことも嫌がることもありません
私も他の生命の称賛 非難などを怒り受けるときは
大地のような心を保ちます
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
はい 次のチャプターは業の創出で
業っていうのは各生命を生かしているエネルギーなんですね
それそれだけ個人所有するものなんです
完全に他人と共有することは不可能です
いたって単純です 話は
自分が食べるおにぎりの味を友達に味わい味わわせる？と思っているです
できません 自分の舌で
自分の神経で 自分の脳みそで判断するですよ
味が だから友達にあげても半分割って
それはその人の体が味わうんです
自分が味わったものじゃないんです
だから味わうということは業がやってるんです
だから隣の人は自分の業で味わってるんです
だからよくありますよ
私は何か食べて これって結構美味しいですよと
食べてみてと言ったら
食べてみて まあどうかなと言うんですね
本人にとってそれも美味しくないみたい
だから味を共有できません
眼耳鼻舌身で起こる感覚は共有できません
自分が音楽を聴いて何を感じるのかと
相手には理解できません
相手が同じ曲を聴いて何を感じるのかと
わかりません それが業なんです
全部自分だけのものなんです
だったら生命を慈しめなくてはいけない
自分はかなり豪華な食べ物を買ってきてね
あまりにも美味しくて
食べて半分誰か友達にあげる
友達はちょっと食べて
えーっと これは何？と言ったら怒って権利はないんですよ
しょうがない それはその人の業なんです
だから この業を相続するということでも
我々は慈悲の実践します
始まりましょう すべての生命は自分の業を相続します
自分の業に管理されて生きています
各生命が受ける幸不幸は
その生命の業の力によるものです
ですから 私は私より豊かな人を見るたびに
過去に善行をした人であると思い
喜びを感じます 私より不幸に思える人を見ると
生命は無明のせいで罪を犯すのだと理解し
自分が罪を犯さないようにときおろします
不幸に陥っている生命に対して
憐れみの気持ちを抱きます
協力する 助ける気持ちを起こします
はい ということで これ私にもこの 4歳の時に母にやられた言葉なんですね
で 私の家にすごい体の不自由な
見る限り子供だったらびっくりして怖くなるような形の人が何か食べ物をちょうだいと来たんですね
母は台所の方で何か仕事をしていた
私はそこでまあもう泥遊びしていたんですね
そこでも変な見ていて
びっくりしちゃって 怖くなっちゃって
やーっと走ってお母さんのところにいて
お母さん変な人動いてるよと言ったんです
お母さん 何のことなく
で で 私と一緒に連れて行って
その人を見て 変な人って何？お前が生まれ変わってそうなったらどうする？ うーん
といったわけです 要するに人を差別するなよなんですね
その言葉を子供には消化できないんだからね
お前も生まれ変わってそんな風に生まれたらね
変な人と言われる その瞬間で子供の時は分かったんですよ
生命差別するとは これはもうとんでもないやと
ですから 私たち思っちゃうね
自分よりかなり体重が増えている人を見ると
変な人ですね タルタルと太り食べ過ぎちゃってね
キモい あれ すごい悪業になる
自分が知らないうちにすっごい悪業するんです
それですごいかっこいい人を見てね
美しくて美しいプロポーションが抜群の女性がいる
ものすごい美男がいるとかね
いいですね こいつらこんなかっこよくて生まれちゃってね
それでしたらこの体はとかね
それで自分自己嫌悪に陥っちゃって人を嫉妬するでしょ
自分が罪を犯しちゃったんです
ただ人を見ただけで だから我々は知らず知らず大量の罪を犯してるんですよ
犬見てもね まあこの犬なら可愛いんだけど
こいつはもうキモいキモい
もうあっち行け あっち行けとか
微妙なところですよ だからしょうがないでしょうね
例えば重度の障害で人が生まれる
障害の中でもね 認知障害というのは一番重度でしょ
何もできない 喋っても返事すらできない
ああ かわいそうな人ですねと思っちゃったら
悪を犯してるんです その瞬間で
あ 業の相続性という言葉が入ってくると
全肯定 あ なるほど 個人個人が自分の業を持っている
この方に今ちょっと悪業が回っているところ
自分にもたくさん業があるんだから
今はちょっといい業が回っているんだけど
将来はよくわからないんだと
だから業の相続性をね
理解すると 差別する気持ちは全く消えちゃって
助けてあげようという気持ちになるんです
笑ってあげようという気持ちになるんです
一応私やっています 時々日本でね
誰にも顔を見ないし 誰にもニコニコと笑いを笑いませんしね
で たまたまいるんですよ
まあこのダウン症とかね
そういう病気でもうの方はね
時々すごい年なんですよ
体でっかいダウン症になってくるとね
あるすごい体が大きい個体な男性の男なんですけど
私を見たら私に何のことなくというような
私の頭を触って こうやっているんですね
私はニコッと見て まあ触らせてあげたんです
そこでお父さんもいたんだけど
お父さんがもうでっかい息子を連れて
okay おじさんもペコペコとすみませんが
で 何やってるのかと子供に怒ったりするんだけど
私は別に で 皆様方 私の頭を触るとなると
どんなもんなのかわかりませんだけどね
でも触らせてあげる だってその人にはそれしかコミュニケーションできないんだから
それしかコミュニケーションできない
だから私は笑ってあげて
だからその人のこんにちは
あなた何者ですか？というところでしょ
でもそれは聞くぐらいの能力を持ってない
だからこうやったんだと
手が高かったんだから
だからその時 自分の心が花が咲いたようにすきすき開いたら
慈悲はやってる人になるんです
気持ち悪かった 怖かったとかね
後で思っちゃうと まああまり瞑想は完成していない
そういうふうに頑張ってみましょう
はい 次に行きましょう
エゴの錯覚 で 私たちはこの生命は一つの波長でいたのに
バラバラになったのはエゴが現れたからなんです
犬にもエゴがあるんです
猫にもあるんです ミミズにもあるんです
だから自分の世界で ミミズはミミズの世界が全てと思っているんです
猫は猫 猫の世界は全てと思っているんです
私たちも私たちの世界は全てと思っているんです
これだからエゴだから
お互いコミュニケーション取れなくなっちゃったんです
はい いきます 私は他より優れていると感じることは高慢です
私は他と同等だと思うことは同等慢です
私は他より卑しい存在であると思うことは卑下慢です
慢とは私のエゴの錯覚から起こるのです
私はエゴの錯覚が心に現れないようにと精進します
私は慢による現れる対立
悩み 争いから離れるようにと精進します
はい 時間も出ますから
次のセクションに行きましょう
苦しむ世界で苦しむなく
まあそれもいろいろ経典を変化させて編集して作った
パーリ語ではすごい美しい文章なんだけど
日本語にするとね 自分の能力のハンディが入ってくるんです
世界は欲によって苦しんでいることを観察して
私は欲を控えることに精進します
世界は怒りによって苦しんでいることを観察して
怒りのない心で生きるように精進します
世界は嫉妬によって苦しんでいることを観察して
嫉妬のない心で生きるように精進します
世界は恨みによって苦しんでいることを観察して
恨みのない心で生きるように精進します
世界はもの惜しみによって苦しんでいることを観察して
もの惜しみのない心で生きるように精進します
世界は自我を張るから苦しんでいることを観察して
自我を張らない心で生きるように精進します
世界は見栄を張るから苦しんでいることを観察して
見栄を張れない心で生きるように精進します
世界は一切の現象は無常であると気づかないので
苦しんでいることを観察して
一切の現象は無常であると認めて生きるように精進します
世界は一切の現象は無であると気づかないので
苦しんでいることを観察して
一切の現象は空であると認めて生きるように
証人します 次の慈悲 世界は一切の現象は無我であると気づかないので苦しんでいることを観察して
一切の現象は無我であると認めて生きるように証人します
私の心に悩みが起こりませんように
私の心に苦しみが起こりませんように
私の心は平安でありますように
私の心に安らぎが生まれられますように
私に悟りの光が生まれられますように
ここにブッダの言葉を原文で唱えましょう
カンティーバラマンタコーティティンカーニンバーナンバレマンスカン
忍耐と観忍は最高の修行であります
涅槃は究極の幸福であります
はい そこで仏教の真理の中に入って瞑想すること
我々は世直しに行かないで
人がすごい苦しんでいる
なんでだといったら嫉妬している
ああ 嫉妬は苦しみを作るんだと
だから自分が嫉妬しないようにすると
その相手を自分の指導者にするんです
二人がものすごい喧嘩している
なんたて言って 何かの原因でわがまま
自分が正しいと ああ なるほど
そういう気持ちでは苦しんでいる
だから私はその苦しみは
この自我を張りませんという風に
自分の心を戒めてみる方法なんですね
だから世界が悟るまで待っちゃうとね
これ話にならんでしょ
観音様と同じ罠に落ち
はめます 観音様悟れませんだからね
もうもう引っかかっちゃったんです
入ってはいけない罠に
はい 次にいきます 冗談置いといて
たまに冗談も言わないとね
私の冗談ってのは人にはすごいひどいじゃないですか
はい 慈しみの拡大 慈しみを無限に拡大しましょう
私の上の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の下の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の前の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の右の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の後の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の光の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
幸福で安穏でありますように
怒り 憎しみ 恨みから自由になりますように
互いに慈悲喜捨の気持ちで接し合えますように
願い事が叶えられますように
心の汚れが徐々になくなりますように
すべての生命に慈しみ
苦しみを乗り越えることができますように
はい それで慈悲の瞑想を終了します
はい ここでお釈迦様が大師匠で
偉大なる師匠で 聖なる師匠で
人間神々の師匠で 我々弟子たちにこういう風な訓練してしっかりしなさいと言っているのです
だから こういう慈悲の瞑想をするということは
お釈迦様にやっぱりニコッと微笑んでもらう行為なんです
みんな頑張ってるんだから
みんな宿題やってるんだと
例えば師匠が自分の生徒たちがね
一生懸命間違いながらね
宿題やってると たとえ宿題が間違っても微笑むでしょ
あ 頑張ってねとかね ちょっと間違ってるのは見えるんだけど
まあまあ そのうち見つかるでしょうとかね
だから今の時間で我々は
我々個人個人がブッダに微笑んでもらうもらえる善行をいたしましたので
皆様方も幸福でありますようにと誓願して終了します
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
ではもう一回サーデュー
サーデュー サーデュー
サーデュー はい これでスマナサーラ長老は終了です
はい まあ疲れましたけど
皆様方はね この私はよく経験したんで
喋る人より聞く人々はクタクタ疲れますね
あの熊野先生のお話を聞きながらね
あの まあ内容はだいたい私も知っている内容でしたけどもね
でも聞いてあげると疲れますね
だからまあしょうがない
皆様の業が悪いんですね
話を聞かなきゃいけない
はい これであの仏教 ウェーサーカ祭りの私の記念
記念講演というかね 話を始まります
あの かなりスピードで
あの熊野先生の話と同じくスピードに行きます
で まあ見えないんだから立ちます
で あの如来は絶対的権威
如来の絶対的権威がつあります
我々を考えている 我々も尊敬しているお釈迦様が絶対的権限を持っている
それで一切の知識の乗り越えたなる
これはもうどんな視点で見ても
その権限 権威はないのです
で これ適切な日本語の単語がなかったんだから
私はまあ一応中単語でそういう権威ですね
これがね 権威 権限でけれどもよろしいんで使ったんですね
感動する 早く行きます
釈尊こそが信頼に値する存在です
出典はマージニーカへマハーシーラですって
12番1番  12番目ですね
で これエピソードがあります
原則的なスナッカッタが釈尊を批判した
スナッカッタという人が出家して修行したんですよ
結構ちょこちょこうまくいったんです
彼にはこの天眼が現れて
いろんな普通の肉眼で見えないものってのをじきじき見えるようになったんで
びっくりしちゃったんですね
ああ こういう次元の生命もあるんだなとか
しかし 彼にとってはこの画像はつながるんだけど
音声はつないでないんですね
だからこの生命体は喋ることを聞きたいんだ
お釈迦様にはこの天地というね
その瞑想を教えてください
言った 言ったら お釈迦様がこの人を試みたら
この人にはこのオーディオチャンネルを作る能力がないんです
ビデオチャンネルはありましたけどね
そこで何も教えてなかったんです
なぜならば ブッダはそれを教えません
ブッダが瞑想を指導すると
その人は必ずその結果を出さなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから偉大なる師匠だから
弟子に生徒に不可能な宿題は出せません
だからこの人 それでクタクタ壊れるんだから
何も言わなかったんで
これは腹が立って 素直になって
嫉妬で私 あ 冷や冷や で
そういうことで減速して
お釈迦様にクタクタ批判するんですね
うん どんな批判するかというと
ブッダに超越した智慧と経験もありません
ただ 整理して組み立てた理論で合理的に話すだけです
しかし 言われる通りに実践すれば結果が現れると
だから本当のことも やっぱり自分には結果あることを言いたいんですね
瞑想したところで ではブッダはブッダじゃない
あれはただ理屈で喋ってるだけ
ブッダの反応 ブッダはこういう風に反応するんですね
この愚かな者が私を批判しようと思って
結局は褒めているのですと
この馬鹿を褒めているんじゃないか
私は 弟子が成功することは
師匠にとって何よりの栄誉でしょうと
だから私が言ったことやったら結果が出るんだったら
これは褒めだと 師匠だからね
それから他人に理解できない相当学者の能力資格について詳しく語られます
だからブッダを馬鹿にしちゃったんだからね
なめるな これぐらい能力あるよと
全部能力リストを言ったんです
それは全部じゃないんですけど
これサーリプッタ尊者に言ったんです
なぜならば理解できるのはサーリプッタ尊者だけなんです
で 一般的には人には言わない
で その能力リストの中にある 4つの項目だけ今日紹介したいと思います
ここで 4つの最小の権利についても語られます
いちおう文字が落ちていますからね
それを入れてください
皆様 聞くだけで疲れるでしょ
だからまあ一応いろいろあります
打ち間違え ブッダは絶対的な権限があって
神でも人間に真理を語っているんです
ブッダにも絶対的な権限を持って喋っているんです
それを覚えておいてください
今日は今日はお釈迦様の日だからね
これは仏教用語で獅子空と言うんですね
日本語で言うとね 獅子空ですかね
ライオン これはちょっと人間のいい加減な感情ですけど
人間がね 勝手にライオンが凶獣の王様と思っているんですね
えっ？百獣の王様だと
ライオンに来たら私は知らないんですね
え？俺 王でしたっけ？王のところじゃなくて
追っかけて苦労して獲物を取っているんだから
それは置いておいてね
しかし だから百獣の王が吠える
これには誰もかなわないんだ
それだけ事実です このライオンの声が本当にすごいんです
その声より上の声はどんな動物にもできない
私は最初にライオンが吠えている声が聞こえて
別に怖くないんですから
動物園の檻にいるんだからね
全然怖くないんだけど
この膝のところで筋肉がドゥルルルッとビビると思うんですね
筋肉が勝手に怖くなっているんです
自分が怖くないのに そこで思い出した
あ 獅子空っていうのは
だから獅子空と言うんだなと思ったんですね
チャッターリマーリサーリプッタタータタサウェーラウェーサーラージャンニサーリプッタには偉大に 4つの権利があります
エイウェーラスウェーサーラッジサマーナタタハと
4つの権利があるのならば
サッバアーサナンターナンパティジャンナティ
師弟に立っている ブッダにかなわない
パリサースシーハナーダンダーティ
大衆の前で獅子空をする
ブラッチャッカンパワーティ
梵輪を回転するんだと
この梵輪っていうのはちょっとおかしい単語で
普通だったら法輪にならなくちゃいけないんですよ
この場合はあえて梵輪という言葉を使うんです
なぜならば 梵というのはインド文化で絶対的神様なんです
だから絶対的神様で喋りましょう
と そういうことなんです
ブッダの言葉はイコール絶対的神様のじけじけの言葉なんです
絶対的神様は存在しませんだけどね
だからブッダは存在しませんからね
だから我々には生命に言われる絶対的言葉は
ブッダからいただいてはいるんです
唯一絶対神のように語るというんですね
はい 次に行きます いち一番
オーソリティーナンバーワン
サンナサンブッダシテパティヤーナトイニーダンマアサンアナディサンブッダアティ
正覚者であると公認しているが
この言葉にいわゆる法と真理ですね
悟ってないのですと言うとなんかおかしい
変ですね 悟ってないのですと
さかんに証拠に基づいて異論立てられる生命はいませんと
まあ頭いかれた連中はいくらでもいますからね
ブッダはすべて悟っているという
誰にもあなた でもこれわかってないでしょ
これわかってないでしょと言えません
だから現代人がブッダが相対理論をわかっているのかと言えるでしょ
で ブッダが宇宙は無限に破壊してあれることまで知っているんだからね
相対理論みたいな理論みたいなもので
くだらない話って何の役にも立たんね
あの物質は自律で存在しないってことすら知ってるんだからね
結局は物質ではないと
だからブッダに知られていないものはないんです
これは知られていないと言っても意味がないとお釈迦様は言うのです
サマノアブラフマンはデーヴァはマーラはブラフマーはコーチはロータスいませんよ
シャモンバラモン カミガミ
マーラ 梵天 また他の誰かがいませんと
私に異論を立てられる人は私に対して
一切生命の中でいません
あ 説明に行きます ミニッタナイタンサーリプッタナサマヌパッサミ
異論立てられる気配すらサーリプッタよ
ありません もしかするとそれもないんです
もしかすると私に反論するかもと
それすらない それぐらい堂々と語っているんです
だからブッダの悟りはいかなるものかというオーソリティーなんです
権威 権限なんです これは絶対的なんです
ミニッタンアサアサマヌパッサトアサマヌパッサトヘーマッパットアベッパットウェーサーラッジャッパットヴィハーミ
異論を立てられる気配すらないから
如来は安穏に達して 無為で絶対的権威を持って生活してしまうと
なんか信じられないね
我々には 生命の中で絶対的権威をも自分の悟りに対する
何のこともない だからこれは自信満々という言葉はよくないんです
これは権威なんです オーソリティーなんです
もっとすごいんです 狙い一切の
真理が明かされているという意味なんです
だから この権威一でいうのは
ブッダは知らないものは一切ないということ
それでお釈迦様はなんでこんな私たちに向かって怖がらせる言葉を言うのかというと
だから素直に言うことをやってなんです
それだけです ごちゃごちゃ言わないで
私 私には知られていないものは一切何もありません
誰かがそう言うんだったら
そんな気配すらないんだよと
もし誰かがあのね あんた知らないものあるんだよと言えるところが
その気配すらないと そういうことで
ブッダの悟りに対する絶対的権威に権限があります
はい  2番目に行きます
キーナーソワスティーパッジャーンとイメーアソワパリッキーナーティ
これから省略します 煩悩を滅尽していると攻撃しているが
あなたにはまるまるの煩悩が未だに残っているのだと
証拠に基づいて異論を立てられる生命は一切ありません
お釈迦様が煩悩完全にして悟っている
微妙にも微塵もこの煩悩まだ残っているでしょうとはできません
あの完全たる姿をインドのインドが覆しちゃったんです
インド人が頭悪いんだから仏教捨てたんだけど
世界では仏教はそのまま現地でやってるんです
だからお釈迦様の仏教は理性のある人のために語っているんだと言ったんだから
アメリカであろうが 中国であろうが
日本であろうが どこであろうが
理性のある人は見ると理解する
その気配すらないのです
如来の心は絶対的に清らかということなんですね
はい  3番目に行きます
ジェーコーパナテーアンタラーイカーダンマブッタテーパティセーワントーナーナナンタラーヤ
意味は解脱に達するために障害になるものだと説かれた事柄がありますが
それらを実行しても障害にはなりませんと異論立てることは一切の生命に不可能です
これ気をつけてください
悟り 苦しみを乗り越えたければ
お釈迦様がこれこれをやめてちょうだいと言うんです
お釈迦様 やめなさいと言ったら文句言わずやめてください
いくら自分がやりたいと思っても
叩きにストップすることになります
そういう人々は悟るのです
で これはなんか変でしょうと
ブッダはあまりにあれやなんて言いますか
一方的ではでしょう そうじゃなくて
しょうがないんです ブッダが知り尽くして言ってるんです
あるブッダの時代 あるお坊さんが
お釈迦様がこの性的な行為を修行する人は解脱達する人はまずそれをやめてくださいと言うんですね
別にそれで生物学的に来てことくどくやったっていいんじゃない？とあるお坊さんが思ったんです
思ったら お釈迦様があなた何言うのか
あなた仏教を侮辱しているんだと
やめなさいと言ってもやめません
その時点でこの人は悟れない
自分がもう失格になっちゃったんですね
お釈迦様はあなたこういうことを言ってるんですかと
はい そうです と言ったら
お釈迦様が はい あなたはそのままいてください
私は比丘たちに喋ります
と その人を捨てて比丘たちに説法したんです
だから それで科学的なもので
この肉体ありがたいと思っている場合は
心は成長しないでしょう
肉体はくだらないと思わなくては
第一次禅定は肉体を捨てるところで現れるのです
だから第一次禅定すら現れません
肉体をいじることで楽しみを感じると
だから心の底辺で一番底辺でその喜びを感じている
だから心が成長しない
そういう科学的なところはあるんだから
そういうことを言ってるんですよ
だから他のものでもね
例えば出家にはたくさん物を持たない方がいいんだよと
瞑想できなくなるんですよ
私だけの瞑想会なんかでは
私によく見えることは
時々この歩く瞑想をやっている時の人々はね
まあ確かに可愛いんだけど
自分のカバンがあります
いろいろ必要なものをね
それは必要なカバンもこうやって抱いて
私はこれは瞑想にならないと思いますね
なぜならば こちらに大事なものを守らなくちゃってことになるんですね
だから肉体そのもので修行してないんですよ
私はたとえ鉛筆 1本すらもそばに置いてはいけないんです
服だけはしょうがない
ですから もう自分の大事な何か必要なものがあったらね
もしかすると薬を飲まなくちゃいけないし
あるいは稼いでるんだったらね
花を噛まなくちゃいけない
それはあるかも それでもあれはここで置いておいて
自分のものでないないにして歩く瞑想しなくちゃいけない
座る瞑想するときでも
いろいろものそばに周りに置いておくんですね
女性の方々はまあ冷えたら困りますよとか言って
もうもう今は冷えてないんだけど
一応準備しておくんですね
あれが障害になっちゃうんですよ
それすら だから瞑想を始めた時でも
もう執着はあったままで
もし聞いてきたらかけてやりますと
それが残るんだだから瞑想がただやって頑張ったご苦労さんだけで終わっちゃうんです
微妙なんです だから誘導にやってください
それだけです 簡単です
はい 仏陀に説かれる道徳
道徳の絶対性を示すところです
だからそれは道徳話ですから
仏陀の道徳は絶対的で
もう言ったら言ったり
神の言葉です 神の言葉よりも偉いな言葉です
その通りにやるしかないんです
まあ難しい できません
間違う  それは人間がね
不完全で弱いんだからね
それは別にわかりますけどね
でも自分が自分が失敗したんだけど
ブッダの道徳は道徳であると
それはその通りに守るべきですと理解しなきゃいけないんですね
最後になりましたね ヤッサコーマの手あったい
ダンマを弟子とすぐにそうね
ミーアったからさ サマードゥカカーティ
正しく苦を乗り越える目的であなたは説法をしているが
あなたの教えによって正しく苦を乗り越えることはできませんと
小功に没すぎて異論を唱えられる生命は存在しない
どういう意味かというと
教えを文句を言わず 自己解釈せず
習慣を入れず 実践すれば誰でも解脱に達するのです
その意味です だからブッダがこうしてきて
ただサティですよ サティを実践してください
このこの順番だよ その通りにやってください
確実性がそれだと みんな自分の考え入れちゃうんですね
私はなんだらかんだらの人に見た通りにもちょっとやっていますとかね
それダメです だから日本ではなくて
世界で瞑想道場もたくさんあるでしょ？ヴィパッサナー瞑想道場もたくさんあるでしょ
あのシステムのやり方
このシステムのやり方とかね
そうやって工夫するのは絶対に外れません
だから私はスマナサーラのヴィパッサナーを教えていないんです
ずっと経典に精密に沿って仏陀の瞑想を教えて
ですから 私が言っていることはその通りかないと皆さんは
経典を調べると皆様にも発見できます
でも学者が翻訳したところで
学者が気づかないところは大勢ありますから
まあそれは私の問題ではありませんだけど
私はたまたまもうチェックするんですよ
チェックすると自分で勝手に楽しくなっちゃうんです
ほら 俺 しっかりお釈迦様の教えに従って教えてるんだとかね
一人で自慢するんです
誰も褒めてくれませんから
はい それで結論 ブッダの言葉は絶対的な真理です
完全に信頼する価値があります
私たちの自分の考え 自分の価値観あるのは当然ですが
私は相当学者ではありませんね
それはご自分の文章なんですよ
ご自分にも自分の考えあるでしょ
これは当然ですよ 自分の価値観あるでしょう
しかし 自分が相当学者じゃないでしょ
だから自分の意見はいつでも置い-置いといて
ブッダの意見に沿って修行しなくちゃいけないんですね
私意見 見解を捨てて実践する人は悟ります
だから我々に悟るためには
もう二日でも十分ですよ
まあ三時間 四時間やっても四日でも悟りますよ
一つポイントは 私意見捨ててくださいなんです
だからもう説法でこれ私意見ね
破ってあげることもできますけど
まあそれはあまりも他力になっちゃいますからね
やっぱり自分の意見をなくなったら
自分の考え壊れたところで喜ばさせて
自分の考えが壊れていくと
ブッダが教えた真理はそれに入っているんです
人の話と比較したっても
新しい見解を入れただけ
壊れたわけではないんです
ブッダの教えを改良しようとすることは
仏法僧を冒涜することになります
賛美しない限り その人は悟りません
だからブッダの教えはちょっとでも改良しちゃうと
その人がもうアウト 悟れません
賛美しない限り そういうことで危険なところなんです
はい これで今日のウェーサーカ記念講演は終了です
カンティー パラマン タポーティ ティンカー ニッバーナ パラマン ワダンティー ブッダ